la transcrit Axel Govin elle adapte sa
probablement et la traduit en français
éditions
bonne foi messieurs la fois la menton
bois il fait un grand bal pour toutes
les animaux
toutes les animaux presque toutes pour
toute cette Nena la corne rien que ça
n'est na la conne les animaux ne la
connais
comme ça le roi il décide lui décide
s'acclivait
la conne
oui entrez tortue la conne la pointe
lapin
lapin ça n'a la conne
lapin satnena la conne ça les rat comme
la conne lapin lapin rentre pas
jusqu'à bouffer le service il faut la
connaître cabri
ice
en crânées dans son vativien il prend
connaissance l'invitation le roi
Elie balle y aime ça
yeah y arrive devant le salon
Lilou quand
rien
la musique c'est une leçon maloya il
moule malheur en plus le temps c'est la
petite fille le règne roule plateau
salade il passe jolie salade bien quand
bien paumé bien frais
en plus patte joli tisane email
menzelsanimo si vous préfèrent
jolis animal en zizi ton poponette en
rose bonbon
mais saumon le roi l'a fait mettre
gardien partout
m'y connais le roi l'a dit nanazanimo
la.com va essayer de rentrer
en distance dès devant barreau troisième
dans l'allée quatrième devant l'entrée
Salvaire
lièvre il debout dehors du regard
liliante un moment donné il prend un
cœur monsieur laisse-moi rentrer pour
moi écoutez un peu la musique qui
l'autre conne ou la.com
poulie abandonner ni quoi dans le bois
lui trouve un bon bas dans un trou de
bois litière gâteau de miel il tient la
cire
des jolies petites ça y est claque en
bouteille les plus jolies que toutes
cornes
son petit corps collé admiel bipasse la
point jeunes gens plus jolie
tout is animal y avait pas localise en
plus d'embala il fait comme un radioché
ça qui veut chanter il chante elieve
c'est un chanter consomme toi y arrive
il chante un coquin pour le moisana
sanguin
tout is animait lui battent la main
bravo bravo bons animaux bonhomme il
arrête boire pour battre la main bravo
bravo bons animaux Madame Y a arrête de
manger bah de Bado
dièse même il gagne quoi
idialdi à chante encore
lion chante et arrête pas chanter tout y
battre la même bravo bravo bravo un joli
tisane email il vient au fait à Liège
pour boire lièvre
pas bien entendu
mais elle est trop jolie pauvrement
un petit bijou
le 17 dansants
toutes animaux y battent la main
Simon gel jolie jolie main plus joli
encore il saute l'autre coin là-bas il
vient y aller monsieur la table
idrissait pour vous monana mon petit
chaise bien sûr monsieur
il y a 6 Momzelle côté de lit à gauche à
droite monsell en face manzole Limoges
il faut les sauver un instant pour
prendre un petit peu les frais Talia il
va rendre dans le salon
Balzac animaux il se passe la journée
pas la nuit dehors donc gros soleil
devine un peu comme ça la rivière que ça
arrive son code en sia dans qui a soleil
inerte
devine saclarive à lit quand il a essayé
rentre dans le bal de vie que ça le
chien gardien l'a fait oui qui est
obligé courir sauver oui le chien la met
des Ali il dit comme ça
zodi encore
lièvre les soufflets lequel il bat ton
corps dans son dos